okay let's bring you a briefing that's
being held with the Israeli Army
spokesperson Daniel hagari let's listen
in any position that is trying
to attack Israel regarding the captives
and those who lost their lives we have
told
38 families that uh and
222 222 cap
and
308 dead we have told their families and
uh we have let them know about the
situation of the sons there are also
some foreigners and it will take time to
know more about those
foreigners these figures that I told you
are the final figures
222 captives and and we have told the
families
we we are in contact with these families
the offices of the IDF are in contact
with these families and we will do
whatever it takes we will exert whatever
efforts the situation needs to return
the captives to Israel now it's time for
some questions question from Channel 11
why didn't or haven't you started the
ground attack I need to repeat myself
again we will use every method in order
to release the captives and return them
back to their families the intelligence
people are doing their job and uh uh uh
this is one of the the main target is is
to eliminate Hamas and to eliminate
their military power these two
objectives will be achieved in the best
way in
order to be good enough to achieve our
goals the is the IDF ready for the
operation to start the ground attack in
Gaza what about the political
decision the military capability of the
IDF is are being improved so much and
uh the war planes are attacking so many
military points where the terrorists are
in order to PVE the way for the second
phase of the war the aim is to eliminate
any threats from Hamas we need to
increase our capabilities and our
Readiness to start the ground attack in
a better
way okay that was Israeli military
spokesman Daniel hagari there speaking
he said that ground forces have
conducted limited raids into Gaza to
kill gunmen and search for the Israeli
hostages he also confirmed the number of
people held by Hamas in Gaza is 22 to he
also said that they're monitoring the
situation to ensure Hamas doesn't get
any of the aid that has uh gone through
the rougher Crossing into Gaza and is
ready to mount operations to prevent
such seizures